So the sportswriter
came in and he
said, listen, man, I haven't
seen a performance like that
ever in my life.
He says, I want to
give you a nickname.
Earvin, we got to
call you something.
Somebody's called Biggie,
somebody's called Dr. Jay.
How about Magic?
You know, you're
like, yeah, right.
[LAUGHS] You start
laughing like,
OK, my boy is not
going to call me Magic.
And within two months.
Everybody in Michigan
knew who Magic was.
And I had heard about this kid,
you know, Earvin Magic Johnson.
I was like, who's this
dude, Earvin Magic Johnson?
Never saw him but just
kept hearing how great he
was as a basketball player.
Now, he goes,
watch it, could be.
He slams it--
Have you seen this
kid in Lansing?
This 15-year-old Black
kid from the Midwest.
They call him Magic.
Have you seen him?
Earvin Johnson, you're a
very sought after player.
You shoot well, you pass well,
you dribble, score assist.
We trying to figure
out what you do best.
Do you know?
We can't figure it out.
When the newspapers really
start getting involved
and then start getting
the big headlines,
you know, that's
when he basically
became the pied piper.
Whatever game he was playing,
everybody wanted to go see it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Everywhere we would go, you
could not find a seat anyplace.
You just could not find a seat.